european union agriculture ministers
have debated ways to help farmers hit by
russia's ban on fresh EU produce and
ensure price stability on the market
last month Russia announced a year-long
ban on mostly perishable fruit and
vegetables meat fish and dairy products
after the EU imposed sanctions on Moscow
over the conflict in Ukraine The
ministers wait options like storing the
produce or finding alternative markets
for it in ways that would minimize the
impact on food prices in the Union they
pledged to keep monitoring the band's
impact we Ave reminisce area Ponte Monte
there was a number of meetings will be
held including over the next few days to
perfect the monitoring process shall
carry on you possibly from a Felicity
will continue the search for all
possible support instruments Russia's
ban could hit you exports worth more
than 5 billion euros in a rapid response
to the move the European Commission set
up a fund of 125 million euros in
support and he marked more than 30
million euros in emergency aid for
peaches and nectarines The ministers
agreed that would be appropriate to look
for support in European budgets other
than farm spending given that the ban
was considered a response to EU
sanctions to further protect farmers
livelihoods countries outside the EU
have been encouraged not to offer Russia
cheap produce to replace European
products while the ban is in place